we begin tonight joe biden's disastrous
first trip abroad
now entering week two and europe's
leaders they
are elated under biden there's no tough
love
there's no america first there's no
accountability there are no difficult
conversations no negotiations
america last policies as joe keeps
saying america is back
america last is back america paying the
bills for the world that's back
and president sippy cup just wants
everyone to go along and
get along and as a result the world is
once again taking advantage
of biden's tremendous clear weakness
and utter stupidity remember it wasn't
that long ago president trump
yeah he went to nato he took charge and
he stood up for you
the american people and he made them
uncomfortable
and they had to pay their fair share
take a look
i have been very very direct
with secretary stoltenberg and members
of the alliance
in saying that nato members must finally
contribute
their fair share and meet
their financial obligations now now
nato alliance members now they're
helping make vladimir putin and russia
rich again
doing billion dollar energy deals well
thanks to
joe's waiver for vladimir as a result
president trump's tough rhetoric
and actions our nato allies they had to
step up they ended up contributing
a lot more new trade deals were brokered
with the uk
an eu free and fair trade trump withdrew
from the insane paris climate accords
that does
nothing to hold china and india
accountable
accountable because they're classified
in the paris accords as developing
countries
now all while sending your tax dollars
abroad and making you pay for pretty
much all of it
some kind of global penance for our evil
polluting ways when we reduce more
greenhouse gases than any country on
earth unsurprisingly the climate
obsessed socialists of europe
they don't want to pay their fair share
uh they much prefer joe biden
who cares more about their approval than
the well-being of you the american
people
but to be honest it's not clear that joe
biden still frankly
possesses the strength the energy and
the ability to even know what the word
tough means
joe biden once referring to putin as a
killer but
now ahead of his meeting with russia's
hostile president
the tough talk nowhere to be found he
even publicly agreed to consider a
prisoner exchange something immediately
his handlers had to backtrack on
and today joey couldn't seem to find the
words to say anything at all about
vladimir take a look
vladimir putin laughed at the suggestion
that you had called him
a killer is that still your belief sir
that he is a killer
[Laughter]
the answer to the first question
[Laughter]
i'm laughing too they actually uh
well look i mean he has made clear that
uh
the answer is i believe he is in the
past
essentially acknowledged that he was
there are certain things that he would
do or did do
for those of you in the media mob that
get angry when i call him sippy cup
that's exactly why i call him sippy cup
he needs his warm milky
night night nappy time warm milky sippy
cup time
it is humiliating russia is responsible
for two
major cyber attacks against our country
in recent weeks joe it's you know
it is supplying america's enemies like
iran
with weapons technology and funding so
they can fight a proxy war worldwide on
terror against the number one
state sponsor of terror their aggressive
actions in the middle east
around the world are endangering
american soldiers but joe biden is at
the loss for words
i'm sitting there i'm going one one
thousand two one thousand three one come
on joey you can do it
make no mistake russia is a hostile
regime
putin is a hostile actor yes joey
he's a killer and he's a thug and sippy
cup
well he doesn't even have the strength
the mental fortitude
to ever hold him accountable for
anything this this meeting is going to
be a disaster
how weak putin will see firsthand how
weak joe
is and what we've all been witnessing
that the media mom protects joe from
we know he's a mere shell of the man he
was even five years ago
make no mistake putin loves a weak
america and a weak american president
and of course there won't be a joint
presser with putin
following the summit oh can't put joey
in that position
whatever biden says about putin after
the meeting they wrote that before they
ever went on this trip
i guarantee you it's already been
written joe is afraid
his staff is afraid they are worried
that
what joe says in private he would never
say in public and he'll just give us
talking point lies
after they meet alone because he's
afraid to say it in front of putin in
front of the world
they're worried putin will upstage him
because he will
and make him look bad because he will
and they're worried that biden
will be humiliated yet again on the
global stage as if this weekend wasn't
embarrassing enough
just take a look at the past few days
joe has been an embarrassing
international laughingstock this was a
great moment at one point europe's
leaders
all mocking joe right to his face
after he became incredibly confused
during a meeting
then he had to well tell uh the prime
minister
of great britain um well maybe you
should introduce the president of south
africa
i already did joe take a look
to welcome those who have just joined us
bringing
some pretty spectacular weather with
them
our president
and and the president of south africa
because
as
i hate this isn't even funny anymore
that wasn't the only moment of confusion
there were a lot
biden mixed up libya in syria he did it
three consecutive times in less than
90 seconds that has to be a record not
one to be fond of
but a record nonetheless take a look we
could work together with russia
for example uh in uh
in libya we should be opening up the the
the passes to be able to go through
provide
provide food assistance and economic ass
i mean
vital assistance to a population that's
in real trouble
the rebuilding of of of syria
of uh of libya of you know this is
they're there i'm hopeful that we can
find
an accommodation that where we can save
the lives of people
in for example in in libya
is there a betting line about kamala
harris
taking over i know where i'd bet once
again as handel is forced to issue
another clarification and it gets worse
during those same remarks at times
his comments made absolutely no sense
whatsoever and i'm not making this up
take a look
half a billion doses of pfizer vaccine
which we contracted and pay for
in addition the money we put into the
covert project which is that
covert as i know you all know but a lot
of people may not know what covert is
by harassing the full potential of
those who are harassing we're going to
have to try to change things
that's the whole idea
who on earth doesn't know what covert is
this is why the administration works
overtime to limit biden's off-script
public interactions
even the first lady doing her part over
the weekend she literally jumped in and
dragged
joe away when he seemed to be in the
wrong cafeteria
to prevent him from answering an
impromptu question and yet again at a
press conference joe admitted
uh i'm not supposed to answer too many
questions they won't let me
okay take a look thank you
i'm going to get in trouble with my my
staff yeah go ahead but i
pretended you didn't answer you thank
you very much sir
you have often said repeatedly that
america is
back at the same time you've kept in
place some trump-era steel and aluminum
sanctions
and i wanted to ask you when you're
having these conversations
with european allies who are very
concerned about these sanctions
how do you justify that and what are
your plans 120 days
give me a break need time
come on man are you a junkie i expected
that to come flying out
uh joey you're the president you've been
in office for
145 days and you can answer as many
questions as you want
this is frankly beyond concerning
because tonight america
is entering a extremely challenging
period there are major growing threats
abroad
china russia iran north korea just to
name a few at the same time
there are new serious problems right
here at home massive inflation
violent crime on the rise homelessness
on the rise lawlessness at our southern
border
aided in a better by joe these are
serious
challenges joe is clearly not up to this
job
he puts all of his effort into just
getting through the day barely
his radical socialist base is clearly
running the show
case in point the biggest development
from joe's europe trip
an agreement to consider a global
corporate tax rate
which of course corporations don't pay
pay taxes they pass them on to you
and joe knows that corporations will
leave the us
so he's trying to conspire with the
world's other socialist countries
to ensure there's no tax haven country
to ever exist
this will end in a worldwide economic
disaster as a matter of fact
the entire the trip trip and they were
just touching
tip this is the tip of the iceberg an
unmitigated failure
and it's only going to get worse hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else